on the first day of pitch miss my true
love gave to me my kid got a spell a
family on a second day a pitch miss my
true looking to my awesome nerd the
third
[Music]
my true
[Music]
see
[Music]
[Music]
I love you want some nerds so on the
tour we've got three bands say hey to
the new group hello we're the Bellas
formerly a Barden University and
currently of life you guys are seeing
other people's songs right oh my god um
guys stop they just don't like sharing
the spotlight so they're trying to
intimidate us
thinking what I'm thinking what is that
a reef off yes yes what is it refer a
riff off is a little game that we like
to play we start with a beat oh yeah oh
go ladies
[Music]
[Music]
with all my belly
[Music]
is that feedback so it's singing guys
still need that level check for vocals
Oh baby we're just getting started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I was fine
[Music]
they just swallowed by themselves by
using musical instruments but is done
we won guys we should go
we won fellas are doing what they do
best quitting here's the problem John
the Bellas are not as good as the other
bands that is a startling insight
[Music]
how many ladies were going to show gun
nut we are not a joke
let's not to finish this try to have
some dignity we don't do anything we
have dignity okay
what a beautiful every one of them going
nowhere so what do you want to sing
tonight I brought this just a date we
didn't invite you guys to sing we
invited you to watch excuse me I just
thought you guys were so busy with your
awesome jobs and amazing lives I am
actually you're so bright and shiny
still pretty they look like they was all
breastfed rigueur the USO puts on this
performance to support the troops in
Europe one last show together who is
with me oh yeah
[Music]
welcome to Spain fellas so this is the
first base will we be going to second
base with you guys that's a no for me so
on the tour we've got three bands you
guys are seeing other people's songs
right like a cover band they're trying
to intimidate us let's just do it to a
reef off
we like to keep it oral
is aware that everybody is that are at
the one thing that we do then
then we are at that thing alright ladies
pick up your tits we're going to show
them that we are not a joke my record
label wants to sign one of the bands but
we don't want the balance we want you
what I did not see this coming their
family we support each other we like
sisters Aubrey he is Aubry isn't it I
can't I'm part of the group Becca it's a
big opportunity for you
[Applause]
[Music]
bye-bye Bela's it really does feel like
goodbye John Becca what are you doing
don't yeah if you cry I'm gonna cry
don't make that face I'm not doing it
don't make a face this is my regular
face
[Music]
you